the International Life Sciences
Institute in Washington DC's sounds
harmless enough but the new study
suggests the ill see is home to a very
powerful lobbying group working on
behalf of the US food industry the
Institute aims to promote science for
the public good and to be transparent
and denies it functions as a lobbying
group but the study just mentioned begs
to differ
claiming for example that the ill sees
nutritional advice is not for the
benefit of consumers the Institute
offshoot in China is said to have
influenced the governments anti obesity
program resulting in guidelines that
downplay the role of a diet in India the
LC reportedly obstructed government
efforts to flag up potentially unhealthy
foods a few decades ago it also
championed the tobacco industry's
interest in Europe and America while
more recently it supported claims that
are widely used weedkiller does not
cause cancer the institute's website
boasts that it's an NGO working to
promote health and the environment it
does not mention who its donors are
reportedly these include coca-cola
PepsiCo and McDonald's here's how the
studies seeking to expose the ill see
describes its activities LC seeks to
influence individuals positions and
policy both nationally and
internationally and its corporate
members deploys as a tool to promote
their interest globally
you